guys welcome to create and cultivate
you're about to deliver your keynote
what do you hope people take away from
the messaging that you are gonna share
with us today we hope to leave all of
the female entrepreneurs here inspired
and we hope that everyone leaves feeling
like even if no matter how big or small
it is there's a way that you can use
your business to get back what Hannah
said I think this is you know such a
great event I think all all the one who
come here are so inspired by the
different stories and kind of hearing
you know everybody's journeys so
different
oh yeah I hope people leave inspired you
obviously have a major Empire but then
you started the nonprofit the little
market what was it that you really
wanted to do with this business we
wanted to help women that was I mean
that was really it we wanted to help
women in underserved communities we have
long story of how we used to travel
together and we were always going to
little markets and seeing female
artisans everywhere and we felt like we
were in a position to give them a
platform to sell their goods so do you
want to add to that yeah no I mean I
think we really wanted to find a way to
help people who needed help selling
their products and earning an income and
we also constantly hear from women here
that they want to figure out how ways to
give back but don't know how and so
through product purchases a little
market you're actually giving back you
are so young when you started your
businesses and you are still so young
but like really you are so young what
would Lauren today say to LC back then
oh man hopefully nice things I don't
know I probably just to be kind to
myself I think it's when you're a been
working really hard you can be kind of
you know your own you
biggest critic so I feel like you were
like that yes I'm surprised to hear that
yeah I mean I think everyone's like that
at a young age were kind of figuring who
you are and you're making mistakes what
you're supposed to but I think you can
be kind of hard on yourselves so you did
sort of inspire an entire generation of
women to move to Los Angeles in a way do
you feel a responsibility to sort of
share I mean we watched you grow up but
we haven't really seen like you're a
little bit more private now do you feel
is that intentional yeah I I gave a lot
of my life for many years so I I'm just
and I really value my privacy I I like
having a moment and knowing that I'm
just sharing it with my family and and
not broadcasting it so it's just really
valuable to me probably nice friendships
that you have to really have you guys
been friends for somebody told us that
it was more than ten years
decade is it hard to balance the
friendship with business are there rules
in place no no I mean not rules there
was there were expectations we
definitely if we set out to do this we
were really clear about the rules we
would play and what you know what they
were and how often we would be working
and doing things and I think that when
you set that in the very beginning it's
it's a smoother sailing I mean people
are very invested in you you know this
what would it take to get you back on
reality TV is that weird that we still
care so much no I think it's it's really
nice that's a huge compliment um I'm I'm
not gonna do it but I appreciate that
why won't you do it
to be honest I just my priorities have
changed me know my family's number one
and it takes a lot to be on reality
television it takes a lot emotionally
it's a lot of time commitment and I did
it for a really long time and I'm so
grateful for my time on television but
I'm in a place now where between my
family and my career like I've got a
pretty full plate so I'm not looking to
add anything where do you see the
nonprofit the little market going
over the next five years and where do
you see your empire kind of going over
the next five years we hope to grow the
little market as big as possible because
the bigger it gets the more women we can
help and so we hope to be able to add on
more artists and groups more countries
and serve more women that need work yeah
I think I think we're just looking for a
growth they think the more we can get
the message out and kind of tell our
story you know the more artisans we can
reach today is all about celebrating
women I mean your guys's nonprofit does
that too you have two sons how do you
hope to instill those values and
continue the conversation as they grow
up I I think I'm just I'm looking to
raise good people and I I think that you
know the rest follows your mom - what
about for you for me it's the same
Lauren and I talk about this all the
time but being great examples for our
kids and teaching them to be as good as
possible
yeah sure hang what is the next the next
chapter of the little market I mean are
you guys gonna expand are we gonna get
more clothing from you could we get
another book from you um yeah I yes and
yes like a memoir could that ever be
anything I mean I hope I'm too young to
write a memoir gosh Simpson did it I
she's lived a a more interesting life
than I have I think yeah I have a couple
of things coming out this year that I'm
really excited about a couple of
projects that have been a few years in
the making so I have a very exciting
year
[Music]